what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today we're going to
be talking about what all of the Marvel
fans have been waiting for and that is
the X-Men in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Marvel Studios has been teasing
us quite a bit lately with the X-Men in
both some good ways and some bad ways
they officially told us that X-Men exist
in the MCU and made kamalakon the first
mutant ever to be introduced in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe also in last
week's episode of She-Hulk while the
credits roll we saw all of the sketches
that we normally see and this time we
saw pug looking at a bunch of different
shoes and we saw some shoes designed
after a few X-Men cyclops included so
another good tease there but here's the
bad tease in 2019 San Diego Comic-Con
the last thing that Kevin feige said was
we didn't even have time to talk about
the mutants and the Fantastic Four so we
assumed that this year's San Diego
Comic-Con he would talk about mutants
however ever he didn't then we assumed
that at d23 since they didn't talk about
mutants at sdcc they would then at the
d23 Expo and then they didn't again but
it looks like we figured out why in this
video I'll be talking about how I
believe the X-Men will enter the MCU and
it will start before Secret Wars however
not in the exact way that you expect it
to well sadly I think the report about
the X-Men not coming until 2025 is true
but that doesn't mean that we aren't
going to see the mutants until then and
I'll explain where I believe we'll see
mutants pop up in the MCU specifically
what projects I believe they'll pop up
in and how the actual X-Men team will
enter the MCU Also to clarify I do
believe that the X-Men are already in
the MCU I believe the actual team is
already there the concept art for Miss
Marvel for Avengers con shows a
cosplayer dressed up as Cyclops and he's
in his X-Men uniform this seemingly
confirms that the X-Men do exist the
issue is they won't be fully introduced
used as a complete team for a while but
here's where I believe what other
projects the X-Men will show up in until
we get to Secret Wars and I'll explain
how I think Secret Wars will give us our
first official look at the X-Men and set
them up for phase seven now Miss Marvel
gave us our first official mutant and I
think black panther is the next time we
get our second because in the comics
Namor is a mutant and since they made
Miss Marvel a mutant in the MCU I would
like to assume that they're going to
keep Namor as a mutant as well so
there's our second one now Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania could give us
another mutant introduction and the
reason for that is the Quantum realm and
Janet Van Dyne in Ant-Man and the WASP
they rescued Janet Van Dyne out of the
quantum realm and they made it very
clear that the quantum realm activated
some type of powers within her and since
apparently the MCU is kind of retconning
some mutants stating that some people
are mutants that are not in the comics
like Miss Marvel they could say the same
for Janet van and dine stating that she
had the mutant Gene and the quantum
realm simply awakened it inside of her
they might not go that way but there is
that possibility since they already kind
of teased us with that in the last
Ant-Man movie now following Quantum
Mania secret Invasion definitely has
some big possibilities of introducing
some mutants as well specifically I'm
thinking Mystique this gets a little
tricky if that 2025 rule is true them
not being able to use any type of new
X-Men characters in the MCU until then
but clearly Secret Wars is going to be
all about the scroll invading Earth and
the scroll shape-shifting and taking the
identities of Shield agents or sword
agents or anybody important basically
and anybody that's been important over
the past 10 years and since they're
talking about threats that can
shapeshift I automatically think of
Mystique so this would be a perfect time
to at least mention Mystique at least
mention that there are people other than
scroll out there that have the ability
to shape-shift this could be a major nod
to towards Mystique in the MCU so even
though we might not get an official
setup for mystique or another X-Men in
secret Invasion I am really really
hoping they at least give us some hints
and teases now the echo series Guardians
of the Galaxy vol 3 Loki season 2 and
the Marvels I don't really think they're
going to be too much of a mutant
connection there that is as far as
introducing New Mutants however the
Marvels will have a mutant in the movie
because it will have Kamala Khan Miss
Marvel in the film they could also say
that perhaps Monica Rambo is some sort
of a mutant and her powers were awakened
because of the mutant Gene as well it
just kind of depends on what Marvel
Studios wants to do but then we have
blade and I'm really really excited for
blade but blade could definitely throw
in a mutant in that film but I'm hoping
it throws in other characters like Ghost
Rider I'm imagining that they'll
probably stick to more Supernatural
things and probably give Blade the focus
and Spotlight in his own movie of course
but there is potential there now
ironheart and Daredevil were probably
not going to get anything about the
mutants in those series however Agatha
Covenant of chaos we probably will get
at least a little bit of it because I'm
assuming the Scarlet Witch is at least
going to be mentioned because it did
seem like in one division they made it
kind of clear that the stone simply
awoken something inside of her which
could be the mutant Gene now we're not
really sure how much Agatha coven of
chaos is going to dive into Wanda and
the Scarlet Witch but considering the
fact that Wanda is the one who kind of
imprisoned her I'm assuming we'll get at
least a little bit and Agatha could make
a joke about it stating that it was the
Scarlet Witch which isn't supposed to
exist but also a mutant and also a
person whose Powers were magnified by an
infinity stone that's why she lost to
her so they could make a joke out of
that now Captain America 4 is rumored to
be about super soldier serum and it's
actually rumored to have multiple Hulk
cameos so I'm not assuming we'll get
much about mutants there but the
Thunderbolts definitely has some
potential specifically in regards to a
possible villain the Thunderbolts could
be tasked with taking down a villain who
could be a possible mutant I think
really anything is game with this movie
but then of course we get to phase six
and this is where it goes down but where
it also gets kind of weird Deadpool 3.
there was a report that Deadpool 3 was
going to bring in some of the former
X-Men from the fox Universe into our MCU
and recently we've heard some evidence
that actually backs this up the actor
Stefan kapick who played Colossus in the
Deadpool films attended a Comic Con in
Wales and he stated that Deadpool is
going to be filming next year which also
seems to confirm that he is going to be
coming back as Colossus well Deadpool 3
is supposed to take place inside of the
MCU so it looks like that report could
be true and Deadpool is going to be
bringing some friends with him and this
is sort of a legality loophole the deal
says they can't cast new actors to play
X-Men roles that have already existed in
the fox universe but they can bring the
actors and the characters from the fox
Universe over to them to you and this is
what they're going to do for Secret Wars
they're going to combine old X-Men from
other universes because remember it's
all about incursion universes combining
and they're going to combine that with
New Mutants from our universe Avengers
Secret Wars comes out at the end of 2025
in November that means they have time to
include some new X-Men in some projects
before then but here's the kicker I
think Secret Wars specifically the
ending of Secret Wars is really going to
start off the official X-Men team in the
MCU in phase 7. we'll have a few New
Mutants introduced by the end of phase
six and we'll also have some old ones
from the fox universe and from other
universes like the ones that we saw and
Doctor Strange and the Multiverse of
Madness these are all going to come
together in secret Wars so the existence
of mutants is going to be made known by
Secret Wars and definitely by the end of
the film and I personally think that
after this they obviously can't ignore
the fact that mutants exist and they
need to address this and they need to
seek out mutants in their own and to you
in their own Universe the characters in
our universe will see that the X-Men
team exists in a few other universes and
will question if it exists in their own
universe and I personally think that
this would be the perfect post-credit
for Secret Wars they show a scene of
somebody one of the main characters
talking about mutants and asking if the
X-Men or the mutants exist in their
Universe in which Professor Xavier then
rolls up and says we do I think this
would be just the perfect setup for
phase 7 which I do believe is going to
focus heavily on the mutants and I also
think it's just it would be the best
post credit scene ever again that
concept art from Miss Marvel shows us
that an X-Men team should exist already
and you can't have the X-Men without
Professor X and this is how I believe
the X-Men are going to be introduced in
the MCU throughout Phase 5 and phase six
until we get to phase seven where it
really focuses on them but let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and let me know if
you think a specific X-Men could be
introduced in a specific project do
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof